My name is Ali Abu Awwad.
I'm a Palestinian who was born in West Bank from a refugee family.
I was born to a political family.
My mother was in prison for resisting the Israeli occupation.
I was in prison for four years and I have lost my older brother Youssef.
He was 31 years old.
He was killed by Israeli soldiers.
From that background, I have decided to take the pain to another direction,...
...investing it for a better future.
When I was in prison, I started studying about nonviolence.
Nonviolence is the best art, it's a human art.
This is the most honest and difficult place.
And when I say "painful hope", it is painful.
Peace is painful because it is a solution,...
...because it is a responsibility.
It is a place to reconcile with yourself, first of all.
After a process, after years, I found that the Palestinian freedom...
...should pass through Jewish hearts and minds.
If we can create trust and overcome the fear...
...and really build a realistic partnership which can work on the ground together,...
...we will be the happiest two nations on the planet.
So this book is not another story about a nice Palestinian who's talking about peace.
No.
It's a Palestinian who has been involved and engaged in violence and knows very well...
...that nonviolence is the best way to freedom and security for both sides.
Just through reconciliation,...
...you can create a bridge between the painful past and a better future.
And this is what we need.
So through your help, by supporting my book,...
...I think we can really, together, make a difference in the Middle East.